[Music]
how old do you guys
think the oldest person in america is
113.
currently that's alive yes currently
right now 62
111 okay five
hundred hundred and twenty eight
thirteen hundred thirteen
hundred and eight years old um
okay that's 128. all right well
whoever was closest to 115 or maybe 116
wins i was seven away
who were you i was uh four away i was
115.
i said 115. i was 11 away 115 baby
though 13
15 i forgot huh that was a lot of one of
those
yeah i think she's closest
yeah so hester ford hester with a name
like hester
you know it's 113 years old this
centurion man
wow oh a super sensitarian
and it's a she she yes
is she related to the automobile company
the automobile
i don't think so hester yeah
she is kicking it 115.
how many grandkids and how many like
great great great greats
does she have she probably got a great
gag that's crazy so she's like
she's when she turns 100 she she had 15
years still let me see
check it out what was her birthday yeah
that's what i wanted
her birthday 1832. so this is why it's a
little like fuzzy we don't really know
because they didn't even make birth
certificates back in
sets of u.s census bureau documents
and this is what's created in the
confusion because one set
lists her birthday as august 15 1904
but the other one says she was born in
1905. she's a fraud
so the get her out of here she's
defrauding the
the age thing to get a bunch of
attention her out of here one year
difference
gerontology research group they use 1905
which officially makes her 115 years old
so she could be 16. she lost her making
her the sixth oldest person wouldn't be
the earth wouldn't be the first time a
woman lied about their age
is it her fault it's the [ __ ] senses
who runs the census
women incompetent men i've only seen
census people knocking that are female
same
really i should open the door or guys
with long hair i've seen a lot of that
too
damn but yeah so here's the thing so
they're saying that
she grew up picking cotton on a farm in
south carolina
that sounds sad she married john ford
when her best house when she was 14.
the first of the couple's 12 children
arrived a year later so when she was 15
years old she started having kids
wow 12 kids and then they ended up
moving to charlotte around 1960
12 kids 1963 her husband died at the age
of 57.
oh that's young she stayed in that same
house
alone until she was a hundred and eight
years old
alone until a hundred and eight years
wait wait wait wait what about her
what about her kids they all just
[ __ ] left i i
i'm assuming they would visit her
frequently i don't know with 12 kids
you're probably busy with so many
birthdays one once every month
probably so not until she she ended up
falling in the bathtub when she was 108.
that's when they ended up like she
started
living oh my gosh she's the commercial
the life alert commercial
my grandma could learn from this chick
my grandma's falling in the bathtub at
85.
this chick took to a hot into 108 to
fall in the bathtub she could be your
grandma's
grandma right her balance is way better
your grandma way better that's what i'm
saying
it's crazy because she only brews her
head or her ribs damn
oh my goodness she's strong with two
daughters knows how to fall
yeah so now she uses a walker she knew
jiu jitsu
yeah but they're saying she's sharp as a
tech and she's able to recite the
23rd psalm without a single stumble
that's freaking duplicate her genes do
you know who the first oldest person is
what's the oldest the oldest person
currently right now
in the whole planet i'm sure you can you
can guess
what her ethnicity is okinawan japanese
japanese
i don't know if she's from 230 no she's
not that far off
from from this from hester hester yeah
she's actually 117 years old oh [ __ ] and
her name is
kane tanaka this is what she looks like
how many babies does she have i don't
know i don't know her life she populated
all of japan
what i love about all this is that we
always ask them the question like what
are you doing with your diet like how do
i how do i make it to this tell you her
diet
but like hester's when you look at these
people like they're covered in spider
webs basically
it's like do you really want that life i
don't know man i don't know
i know especially if she lived that long
she outlived all of her kids
yeah all of her kids are dead right
most of them all of her grandkids are
dead you know what i mean like it's like
grandkids that old age it's almost like
you're immortal right everyone that you
knew
is just dead it's life of pain you know
what's crazy she's lived through
uh two world wars wow the 1918 spanish
flu
i can't remember them very clearly
though yeah yeah
well she's sharp as attack apparently
did we act as stupid during the last
pandemic
because i don't think anybody was alive
during that time but we can ask hester
she was saying like hester because the
great granddaughter was
saying that hester had told her like why
are you guys wearing all these masks
like
what's going on with the mask and then
they were explaining to her like the
pandemic and stuff but
that's where the story ends but i'm like
see and then yeah yeah but i'm like i
want to know what her response to that
is like oh yeah i remember when i was 13
years old
1918. well she probably fell asleep
right after the response yeah she's like
oh okay
yeah cause we see uh pictures of people
wearing masks all over new york and san
francisco and stuff and
so maybe wherever she was at
i'm assuming mobile alabama when she got
married is when the span
the spanish flu pandemic happened dude
when 9 11 happened she's she's probably
like i'm almost out of here anyway
and then she's still [ __ ] here bro
she's like all right [ __ ] kovid all
right i'm almost out of here anyway
no why she says that she hopes to oh no
the other uh kane tanaka hopes to live
to 120.
she's three years away that's insane
what about the other five
i don't know just the oldest and then
you know the yeah and the oldest
living american is hester yeah
that's amazing i know imagine like all
the [ __ ] you've seen you've witnessed
your whole life
probably buzz boring it's probably
boring well you probably see a lot but
you don't remember any of them
oh that's sad i'd rather not live that
long than i found cause like you know
like
i watched game of thrones probably three
times but i watched a bunch of other
shows after
i remember half the [ __ ] that happened
in game of thrones some of the skits
that we even filmed i forgot
until i watch it i'm like yeah i did do
that huh dude i forget what happened in
love island last night
oh yeah i forgot what we talked about in
the last episode of this show like we
don't have good hard drives you know
no we don't i don't remember anyone's
name in this room
see i forget what article we're talking
about during the article yeah all the
time like the last one joe was like is
this an off the record
but the message part about living longer
is how many things you can
taste for experience
but then if you have dentures and you
got nothing but gums and [ __ ] and
you just nothing sits right anymore
you're just kind of like
i don't want to eat that yeah if you
can't travel anymore let me die already
and then you have no more spit in your
mouth
yeah tell me what they're doing that's
so fun
i did watch this documentary of these
okinawan geezers
and this grandma was like 90 ancient
years old
and she put on a wetsuit and started
diving for oysters amazing at five in
the morning and her [ __ ] younger
husband was on the boat just chilling
and just following her
that's dope all the ladies there they're
like from 80 to like a hundred or
something
in okinawa it's called a blue zone i
don't know if you heard of a blue zone
but all these areas that have a lot of
yeah loma linda is one of them yeah and
um yeah okinawa has a lot of centurions
or centennials or whatever the [ __ ] and
then yeah they're it's so funny like
their lifestyle is like they just play
every day like we just wake up and we
die for oysters
and that's all i do and then they they
all go and visit
the uh the kindergarten and [ __ ] and
they play with the kids
and then they fall that's how they're
staying alive
they literally just [ __ ] around all day
they just
they they always say it's like oh it's
the [ __ ] bitter melon that's why
or they'll be like it's because i eat
this like rice
every day or they slip they're like oh
it's because i eat a lot of uh corn corn
that's
adrenochrome i mean uh cauliflower
that's where it is i want to play every
day sounds fun i feel like a lot of that
is like
that mindset as you get older right
because i feel like my parents and my
girlfriend parents
are around the same age but my parents
are like they're in they have the
attitude with
where they're like we're too old to do
anything let's go do this that's that's
this is fun that's fun they're like no
we're too old for that while my
girlfriend's like mom
she still goes bodyboarding she's like
70. she goes bodyboarding she goes
dancing that's awesome stuff every day
she's healthy she'll stay out like all
night dancing with her friends that's
sick
what kind of dancing ballroom dancing
i've never gone with her
oh you should go yeah you could see what
kind of dancing
imagine she's she's like somebody come
gator she's dancing like a street
that would be pretty sick actually
somebody's on tick tock now
for a limited time only is it remember
when we went to that cruise and those
old people had more energy
to party than we did yeah i was tired i
was like damn how many times are they
gonna play ymca on this [ __ ] ship
dude
yo that shit's hype yeah i love ymca
every single time
they play that ymca though it gets those
old people going
man they love that song they love bg's
too oh yeah these
are bg's gets them moving bg's are
[ __ ] great for sure oh yeah is that
like
their era of like that was the [ __ ] that
song was like always in all the clubs
dude staying alive was like the [ __ ]
yeah
staying alive that's their anthem now
what is that yeah that's
the office oh my god
i was afraid i was petrified he's always
quoting michael scott it's [ __ ]
hilarious
oh mikey scott yeah oh i thought he i
thought he was listening to sick music
no he goes
because the lady tells him like you go
to the beat of staying alive so he
starts at the beginning of the song
instead of instead of ha ha
ha ha staying alive cpr class i see i
see yes
he started from the very beginning
that's where we're at we're doing office
quotes
yeah yeah always
you